VIKAS MARWAHA: Hey, guys.
Welcome to Google.
Today, August 15, it's
Indian Independence Day.
Happy Indian Independence
Day to everyone here.
It's an honor and privilege
to have at Google today
soulful singer Kunal Ganjawala.
Kunal is here in
the Bay Area today
to support a a noble
SAI Global Mission
in its charitable fundraiser.
This organization implements
free food and medical camps
over 250 villages.
It reaches over 400,000
people annually.
I would like to
share a quick video
about the charitable
cause with you all.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
-Service is often considered
a privilege rather than
an essential duty
towards a society.
In this fast-moving world,
despite our busy lives,
it is important to
have focused interests,
to benefit the
poor and the needy,
to uplift remote
villages to help
that section of the society,
which struggles even
for the basic necessities of
life, such as food, water,
medical care, and shelter.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Societal Advancement
Initiative's Global Mission
Foundation was
created in early 2008
as a registered international
nonprofit organization
to further promote
and streamline
the charitable activities
that had started in 2006.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Providing a simple meal
to a starving person
is a valuable service.
We started the food distribution
services in October 2006.
By June 2008, we could
benefit 12,000 people.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We provide free medical services
to 200 villages in five states
of India, with 35 centers.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
-They need a lot of care on
primary health, like anemias,
ordinary fevers,
diabetes, hypertension.
These are the areas where they
don't know what is happening.
-At the facilities
in the villages where
we have attended,
almost all the villages
in the [INAUDIBLE]
district don't have
any proper medical facilities.
-They just lined up to
the outpatient department
here, saying that
they are [INAUDIBLE].
Then on examination at
random, you find that sugar,
it is high, or very low.
Sometimes their blood
sugar is so high,
I wonder how they are able
to sustain it for long.
-If they want to go
and see a doctor,
they do need to travel along,
a least six to seven kilometers
far from their place.
-So naturally, we
are concentrating
on this basic principle of
treating common conditions.
We do have [INAUDIBLE]
other hospitals
in other areas where
we refer patients
as far as [INAUDIBLE] surgery.
We'll be really
happy to know that we
have done a cardiac
catheterization on a girl, 10
years [INAUDIBLE]
where she had a ASD.
And now we have corrected it,
and she can lead a normal life.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
-We know that prevention
is better way than cure.
We have planned some
culturally appropriate programs
to create awareness among people
about their health, hygiene,
and nutrition.
Many patients find it
difficult to travel.
To help those suffering patients
and to reach more people,
we will soon establish a mobile
clinic with basic treatment
facilities.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Serving the victims
of natural disasters
with our emergency
disaster team.
In the coming years,
we are planning
to provide food for more than
2 million people every year.
In line with our global mission,
we have expanded our services
to South Africa.
We also aspire to extend our
services across the glove.
We invite you to join SAIGM
Foundation in our mission
to improve
disadvantaged societies
through compassionate
service, and contribute
to universal harmony and
global moral advancement.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
VIKAS MARWAHA: OK, guys,
hope you enjoyed the video.
We have the founding
member of SAI Global
Mission, Mr. Arvindji Ji here.
I'd like him to talk
about the mission.
Arvindji.
ARVIND THIAGARAJAN:
Good morning, everyone.
First of all, wishing you
all a very happy India
Independence Day.
Thank you for being here and
giving us this opportunity
to come and visit Google.
It's always great
inspiration to be here.
And on behalf of
all of us here, I'd
like to welcome Mr. Kunal
Ganjawala, Mr. Rajesh Uppalapu,
and Mr. Hamid [INAUDIBLE], who
all come from India all the way
to celebrate together with
us our India Independence
Day, as we are moving into
the 70th year of independence.
And we really thank
them for being
part of this wonderful
cause that we're trying
to create awareness about.
And so my name is
Arvind Thiagarajan.
Professionally I'm an inventor
and serial entrepreneur,
mentored by Dr. Abdul Kalam,
the former president of India.
I have a video
compression company,
but I promise not to
talk about that today,
but maybe some other
time at Google.
Today I'm wearing the
hat of our foundation,
called SAI Global
Mission, where we
are doing a lot of service
activities in India.
And we believe
this is going to be
part of the
nation-building mission
through free health
care, education, as well
as nutrition.
It started off in the year
2006, when actually we
were part of a village
service program.
And during a village visit,
we found a very old man,
70-plus-year-old man, and when
we started talking to him,
we found that he was making
less than seven rupees per day,
which is almost like $0.10.
And all he could afford to
eat was just rice and salt.
Now, you heard that correct.
It's rice and salt. If
he had a chili in a week,
he considered himself
extremely lucky.
That's how bad he was.
And because of the
excess of rice and salt,
he developed diabetes
as well as hypertension.
And these are two diseases you
cannot treat by giving medical
care once every six
months or a year.
He needs to have continuous
monitoring and follow-up.
So that's why we developed
this weekly model,
and with inspiration from
great leaders in India who
have really struggled
for our freedom
and emphasized the need
for selfless service
to the society, we
started these activities
on a very noble day,
which is our father
of the nation, Mahatma
Gandhiji's birthday on 2
October, 2006.
And I'm proud to stand here and
say that for the last 10 years,
not a single day has been
missed in terms of these service
activities.
Every week, rain or
shine, our volunteers
have gone to these
remote villages.
It started off with one
village, in Uttar Pradesh,
and today it's expanded
to more than 250 villages.
Every week we have
been providing
free health care and free food.
Now, you wouldn't believe--
you may think, what is this one
meal a week going to do?
But that one meal
a week is going
to really substitute for their
nutrition and other aspects
that they require.
And that creates a lot of
goodwill in these villages,
that somebody is coming
in, providing us free food.
And then that's the best way to
invite them for participating
in these medical care programs.
And a lot of times
we find diabetes,
hypertension is the
number one, number
two problems in our country.
And a lot of times we also
find body pains and so on.
And when we
investigate further, we
find that the water
is contaminated
with flouride content.
Because of that, they have a
lot of problems, and so on.
And some of these villages are
so remote that these villagers
don't even know that there
is a hospital existing,
even 10 kilometers away.
They can't afford it, because
if they miss that day's work,
they lose their seven
rupees, and they won't
have food for the next day.
So it's really bad.
And for some of
these villages, we
had to develop a different
approach, using technology,
to go reach them out.
And what we do here is
we actually maintain
patient booklets for
each and every villager
so that when they come the
next week, even if there
is a different doctor,
he knows what medicine
was given the previous week.
So there is a continuous follow.
And we actually
computerized all the data.
It's available on the cloud,
and a doctor sitting in the US
can actually monitor what's
happening to that patient.
But that was just not enough.
We had to go develop
better technologies
to go reach out to
these remote villages.
So last year we
launched a technology
which is really the world's
first mobile delivery
solution, which is a
bus called SAIWHEELS.
It stands for Society
Advancement and Improvement
by Water, Health Care,
Education, Energy, Through Love
and Service.
And this bus was the
world's first integrated bus
which had solar panels
on top of it, which
can generate electricity.
There is mobile clinic
and then there is also
a mobile classroom with
a library and so on.
And then there is
also a water purifier.
Now, you can see in this
image, some of these kids
have never, ever stepped
into a school in their life.
This is the first time they
get experience to learning
something with state-of-the-art
multimedia equipments
and things like that on the bus.
So that really triggers
the interest in them.
We go there only once a week.
It's not enough to give them
just once a week education.
But it triggers
interest in them.
That's what drives them to go
to school, or do better in life.
Otherwise these kids wander
around doing nothing.
And they're struggling for food,
struggling for basic water,
and other problems.
We actually went to a village
near Raipur in Chhattisgarh,
and this village
is called Persada.
We were shocked because
we went to this place
where there's a lake.
The buffaloes are bathing there.
People are washing their
clothes over there.
And guess what?
The children came and started
drinking that same water.
Now, we live in Silicon Valley.
How can we accept this?
So that's where-- this bus
actually has a water purifier,
so when it goes to the
village, it actually
delivers pure drinking
water to the villages.
And we encourage the villagers
to fill up a 20-liter can
so that is good enough
at least for a week.
If you give them
pure water, that
cuts down half of the
health care problems.
So we are also collaborating
with Stanford University.
We actually hosted a conference
called Science for Society,
using which we are coming up
with an ideal village program,
where using energy, it's
going to self-sustain
all these activities
moving forward.
But that alone was not enough.
We found a lot of children
having heart diseases.
And I'll give you an example.
This one little baby, her
name is [? Twinkle Sahu. ?]
And she actually
had a heart problem.
Her parents knew
about it, and they
knew that she was almost dying.
Literally, her
days were counted.
But these parents were making
less than $100 a month,
and a heart surgery in India
cost much more than $5,000,
$10,000.
And they just
couldn't afford it.
I mean, in our
country here, even
if our pet is
affected by a problem,
we all worry about it so much.
But here they know that
the child is going to die.
What can they do?
And that's where we
started supporting
a completely free hospital.
It was built in the
shape of a heart
in a place called Raipur,
Chhattisgarh, which
is really the heart of India.
If you look at the India
map, that's literally
where exactly the heart is.
And this hospital was
inaugurated in 2012
in November, and it
has been providing
heart surgeries completely free
of cost for these children.
And since their
inception, this hospital
has benefited so many people.
And early this year, our
prime minister Modiji
came and visited this hospital.
This is really evolving into
one of the state-of-the-art
hospitals serving all the
communities from all over
India.
And this was built in a
record less than nine months
time frame.
And on the first
day of integration,
there were surgeries
actually performed.
So this actually
provided the gift of life
for so many children.
And while we can talk
about the numbers in terms
of how many people came
from each and every state
to go through a
free heart surgery,
but for us, more
than the numbers,
the true victory
was this child here.
He was actually
asking the doctor,
it seem, when will
my surgery be done?
When we my surgery be done?
And the doctor is surprised.
Usually the children are
scared about these surgeries.
But the doctors were surprised.
Why this guy is so anxious
to get his surgery done?
But my friend here told me
that apparently this child
actually wanted to finish
the surgery fast so that he
can become healthy,
go to school,
learn, and become a doctor
and come back and serve
in that same hospital.
To us, that is true success.
[APPLAUSE]
So again, we have actually
done close to 2,382 surgeries
completely free of cost,
and 6,517 children screened,
and so many patients in the
outpatient screening is done
and so on.
Now, the need is so much,
the demand is so much,
it's not enough if you
have only one hospital.
So we're building another
new hospital in New Delhi,
and that's going
to be inaugurated
on 26 of November 2016.
The land has been purchased.
The building is
already up and running.
And we're going to install with
all the equipments and so on.
And we're hoping and
praying that Prime Minister
Modiji will come again and
integrate this facility.
So that is the main
awareness we are
trying to create through
this event today.
And from the US,
we want to really
be closely involved,
because this
is going to be a milestone
not only for our country,
but for the entire region,
because not only patients
from India are going
to come and visit this,
but people from all over other
countries in subcontinent,
as well as even
in Africa, people
are going to come for free heart
surgeries in this hospital.
So this is going to
be a real milestone.
It's going to be an
international center
for cardiac care at New
Delhi, near New Delhi.
Now, moving on to
free education,
apart from giving them health
care, which is great, but then
we are to give them the gift
of-- carry a gift of life,
gift of education,
character building.
So that's where we're starting
schools completely free
of cost.
It actually provides
free education.
We've already set up 13 schools
in the state of Karnataka,
and the plan is to have
up to 30 schools, one
in every district in Karnataka.
So some of the school
campuses you can see
are really wonderful buildings.
And students can come
there and stay there.
There's boarding provided,
and completely free education.
And the focus is really
on character building.
And we're also proud
to say that there
is specific initiatives being
done for providing education
to girls.
And that is something-- such an
ignored aspect in our country,
or several other countries.
But these girls have to be
empowered with better education
to give them a better life.
So that's where we're
building-- all this goes.
And as I said, the focus
is truly building them
as better citizens.
And that is what can really
help in nation building.
And I can stand here and
talk much, much more,
but I'm sure everybody
wants to hear
the wonderful musicians here.
But the fundamental
point here is
that if we give them
the gift of life,
and then the gift
of education, you
are truly gifting our
nation with better
citizens for the future.
And I still remember meeting
our former president, Dr. Abdul
Kalam, who was my mentor.
I was reluctant when
I had to move to US.
I used to ask him,
sir, is it OK for me
to move back, move to US?
He said, Arvind, it's OK to
be NRIs, nonresident Indians.
But it's not OK to be
not responsible Indians.
So my friends, the only way
we can make a difference
is by breaking our indifference.
These are our own people, and
they require our self service,
and we all should come together.
So it's not only our mission.
It's everyone's mission.
So we thank Google once again
for giving us this opportunity,
and we thank [INAUDIBLE]
for coming here and being
part of this wonderful event
celebrating India Independence
Day, as we move on to 70th year.
So please join us this
evening and support
this wonderful cause.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS MARWAHA:
Thank you, Arvindji.
This is really amazing,
and it's very, very
Sufi and human of what
you guys are doing.
I'd like you guys to have
a big round of applause
for this noble mission.
[APPLAUSE]
And with this, I would like
to invite our guest today,
the celebrated singer,
playback singer,
from "Bheege Honth Tere"
who won the Filmfare
award for best playback singer,
male, Mr. Kunal Ganjawala,
here at Google.
[APPLAUSE]
KUNAL GANJAWALA: This is fine.
Good morning, and
happy Independence Day
for all the Indians.
It's a proud moment for me
to represent my country.
It's not often that we get an
opportunity to be representing
your country, because
we're not sportsmen,
or corporates who get a chance.
But we do music all
the time globally.
But we're representing our art
form more than our country,
consciously, though we sing or
play music from the country.
I'm very proud and honored to
be part of Sai Baba's service
mission, and have been
very closely seeing it
as a human being, as
a devotee, and have
been a very minuscule part of it
in the last four or five years.
And let me tell you, it's very
enriching, very satisfying,
because what
divinity teaches you
is that love is the
strongest weapon,
and love is the biggest healer.
No point having angst or
anger against anybody,
because love heals the deepest
wounds, and love heals-- love
is the greatest weapon.
And that's why Sai
Baba always said
that Jesus came with
the Sacred Heart,
he came with the love
weapon 2,000 years ago,
and healed the world, and
so did all the messiahs.
And so when he came
and walked the earth,
90 years since this day, he
too healed everybody's hearts
with love.
And he often said that
love in action is service.
And it's only through service
that we can redeem ourselves,
about being selfless as
opposed to being selfish
and about giving
more than receiving.
And I have-- Brother
Arvind, Dr. [INAUDIBLE],
who have been part of Swami's
service mission for far longer,
and this hospital
that we just saw,
which Brother Arvind showed
us, in Chhattisgarh, it's
no short of a miracle.
It's no short of being a temple,
a church, a mosque, a gurdwara,
because when you go there,
you see little children,
some are 1 month old,
some are 6 months old,
who have been through
multiple surgeries.
And everything is free.
And I don't mean to exaggerate.
It may sound like is Kunal nuts?
What's he talking about?
This hospital doesn't
have a cash counter.
None of Sai Baba's hospitals
have cash counters.
Everything from admission to
prescreening to postrecovery,
and the operation itself,
and the operations
that will follow,
and medicine, is all
administered free of cost.
So anybody listening,
not just in this room,
but anybody who is going
to be seeing this video,
may think, so where's the catch?
What do you want in return?
What am I missing here?
Nobody's missing anything.
All that is expected of fellow
human beings all over the globe
is to partake in this
mission individually,
at an individual level, by
sitting back and thinking
that I want to make a difference
to my family, to my community,
to my country.
And it's about sharing
and being selfless.
It's about saying,
OK, I earn one rupee.
I'm going to give 25% of that
to whichever form of service
that I want to.
And it's about the
change from within.
It's about a paradigm
shift in how we think,
moving on from me, me,
me, me, me, to community,
and eventually that kind of
uplifting our consciousness
and taking us inwards,
as opposed to, wow,
so Gucci is on sale today.
Oh, it's Christmas time.
It's that time of the year
where American stores give
maximum discounts.
I forget what-- my sister
is on the East Coast,
and I've got an aunt in
Baltimore and a nephew
here at Google.
So I know there are many
holidays where big sales,
and 60% and 70% and 80%.
So that's fine.
We're all in the material world.
But the idea is to kind of
make that shift from within
and say, OK, I've done
enough for myself.
What can I do for society?
And all these miracles that you
see can happen with all of us.
And we can all be part
of such beautiful things,
in a way, in a
percentage that we want.
It's up to us.
And I invite all the
people watching to come
and partake in this joy of
giving, in this joy of sharing,
and in this joy of
feeling that we're
living our lives in a
worthwhile way, and in a way
that we can, at the
end of our lives, say,
damn, I did something.
And we can all peacefully go.
Thank you.
God bless.
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS MARWAHA: That was
quite a soulful talk,
so Kunal, I'd like
to-- Kunalji, I'd
like to invite you for a talk.
We have known you as
a singer, and today we
got to know you as
a Sufi person who's
associated for a noble
cause, which is great.
So I'd like to--
it's a privilege
that you are here at Google.
So let's just start
some conversation.
I'll give you the mic.
So Kunalji, welcome to Google.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Thank you.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Is this your
first time in Bay area?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: No, I've come
here about four or five times.
But I'm excited.
I'm happy to be at Google.
Thank you for being so
helpful with all our questions
and queries-- weird ones, too.
VIKAS MARWAHA: You said
your nephew is a Googler.
Are you also an avid user
of the Google technology?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Yes,
unfortunately, or fortunately.
The thing is, when
we didn't have Google
or when we didn't have
these search stations,
I don't even remember how
we got some of our answers.
But we would go
into-- I don't know.
It's not a thing that we
look for in a dictionary.
But yeah, you can't
even remember.
That's how much Google's brought
onto the table, so thank you.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So any
of your favorite Google
products that you use, or--
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
Whenever I have a query
or when I'm searching for
things, it's always Google.
So I'm taking back a big
consignment of microphones
from America, and it
was through Google
that I reached this
boutique microphone
shop, which is all American.
And it was amazing how Google
led me to their website,
and it's a phenomenon.
You guys are doing
great work, and I really
thank you for all the
information and all the help
that you provide people who
are looking out for things.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Thank you.
So are you comfortable?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Oh, yeah.
VIKAS MARWAHA: OK.
So I would love to know
how you went into singing.
Tell us your journey
into singing.
How did that happen?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Well, believe
it or not, I was bullied.
It was a sheer case of ragging.
I was completely-- there was no
trace of music or inclination
to be a singer.
I didn't know I could sing.
So not knowing you
can sing comes first.
Not wanting to
sing comes second,
because I didn't
know I could sing.
So here I was in the year
1990 in my high school.
And suddenly these
seniors walk up,
and I was whistling some tune.
It was quite late in
the evening, about 5:30.
And I was sipping on some
tea, and some of these seniors
came up and said, hey,
you can whistle well.
So I'm like, oh, OK.
So you must sing.
So I said, what's
the connection?
A lot of people can whistle.
So they said, no, no, no, you
whistle really well in tune.
So it went on for
about five, 10 minutes,
and then I was trying to
get out of that situation.
So one guy caught
me and I said--
I was trying to act tough.
I said, hey, get
your hands off me.
So the other guy caught me.
So I was in that
situation, and I said,
OK, I'm suddenly in a film,
and there are these two guys
trying to hold two of my arms.
And suddenly I
realized that, man,
all the stuff that we see in the
movies is all-- is all a hoax.
Suddenly when two people
catch your two arms,
you're kind of-- you're
against the wall.
So then I thought of
all the kung fu movies,
and I said, OK, maybe
I should use my legs.
And these guys
were tall and big.
So I said, hey, OK,
let's cut to the chase.
What do you want?
I don't sing.
I've never sung in my life.
So they said, so sing.
I said, look, do you want money?
You guys are bullying me,
right, so what kind of bullying
is this?
You're not hitting me.
You're not whacking me.
You're not making me do a funny
thing, putting my pants down.
I said, what ragging is this?
What is this, singing?
What punishment is that?
But they were
incessantly after-- they
were obsessed with the
fact that I should sing.
So they made me
sing, and I said, OK,
let's get this over with.
And I sang.
And more than them,
to my own surprise,
I consciously sang for the first
time, and they all said, see?
They were all giving each
other high and low fives.
They said see, we told you.
And they gave me a couple
of hits on my head,
and they said, see, we
told you could sing.
And I was like--
so I walked down--
it was a long, lonely
road, walking down, taking
the elevator, going
down to the canteen.
And some of my friends met me
and said, hey, let's go home.
And I said, yeah, OK.
And then before
I went down, they
took me to the cultural
secretary of the college
and said, he's going to
be singing next week.
So it was all in those
five 10, 15 minutes,
my entire life just kind
of-- it was like something
just opened up and,
plop, there was
a portfolio that just
came in and said,
OK, this is your road.
VIKAS MARWAHA: This is great
that you opened up that time.
I remember a similar thing
happening with me in college,
where I had a stage fear, and
my batchmates were after me.
We want you to sing in college.
I was like, I've never sung.
And they were like, it's not--
we just want you to sing.
You can sing.
And I did not sing at that time.
I was scared.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: I
didn't have a choice.
I had four people
trying to beat me.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
That's great.
If I had a chance, I would have
loved to hear your whistle.
I know you sing so
well, but should maybe
ask you sometime to whistle?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: You've seen
the movie "Guzaarish," right?
VIKAS MARWAHA: Yes.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: So
that-- [WHISTLING]
VIKAS MARWAHA: There you go.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: So
that's on record.
With the weather and jet
lag, my lips are pretty dry.
I don't know if I
can do that today.
But yeah.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So
did you, after that,
take any training in
singing, or you just
went with the flow, just
practiced on your own?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: No, I
rebelled against the fact
that my parents encouraged me.
They said, well, you continue
your studies, but how often--
and this was
pre-private television.
Private television
happened in '92.
So this was 1990, and
my parents encouraged
me, which is rare, because
at that time in India,
everybody just wanted
to be a doctor,
an engineer, the fixed--
but they encouraged me.
They said, you must continue
your education, but you know,
it's nice.
You can sing.
Why don't you pick up and learn?
So I joined the
[INAUDIBLE] at that point.
And I learned for about
seven or eight years.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
That's great.
So you started singing jingles,
and I discovered that the doo
doo jingle, that was one of
my favorite-- doo, doo, doo--
that became really--
KUNAL GANJAWALA: I can see.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Yeah,
I drank a lot of milk.
So--
KUNAL GANJAWALA: [? Punjab ?]
and milk go hand in hand.
VIKAS MARWAHA: [INAUDIBLE]
your ad, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
that also encouraged us.
A lot of youngsters like,
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH],
you should drink milk.
That ad was so-- it made
milk look very delicious.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: It did.
It did.
VIKAS MARWAHA: How did
you become a part of that?
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
There's a composer
called Lesle Lewis,
who's part of Colonial
Cousins with the great
Hariharan-- wonderful, great
singer of India.
So they-- Lesle gave
me my first jingle.
So doo doo was the second
jingle of my life that I sang.
And it was just, I
guess, the cosmos.
And it was just God kind
of putting things together.
And he gave me
that jingle, and I
was jobless after
that for four years.
And that was the only jingle.
That was actually my
visiting card, so to say.
But there are and
there have been
so many other better singers
and busier singers in the city.
So it always takes
time for someone new
to kind of come in,
make their mark.
Firstly, you need opportunities
to prove your prowess,
if I may so call it.
So it took time.
But these are fine
arts, and so I held on.
And I had my parents,
who supported me,
because there wasn't really
the pressure to provide
in the family, so that helped.
But they really
gave me the support
to go on and not give up music.
And I really thank my parents,
because it's not too often
that you have parents
that can support you
in a nontraditional career
way back then, 26 years ago.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
So who was your singing idol
while you were growing up?
Wow-- so many-- Lataji, Ashaji,
Rafi Sad, Kishore Kumar,
MS Subbulakshmiji, Mandolin
Srinivasji as a musician--
legend as a musician.
And I've also been
influenced a lot
by great bands and composers
and singers from the West,
from America and from
the UK and Europe,
so from Stevie Wonder to Ray
Charles, to the kind of stuff
Quincy did, to Elvis.
And then from Europe,
great bands-- Sting,
U2, the Bee Gees, all the
legendary-- the Beatles,
like I said.
So phenomenal stuff, and great,
great artists, so all of them.
I've never really looked upon
any one, because music is--
the way I see music, it's beyond
boundaries and it's-- India is
a melting pot of great music.
So is the West.
Because India brought the
whole concept of fusion music
to the West as well, way back
in the '60s with Ravi Shankarji
and Shakti, the group.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So growing
up, was there an environment
in your family with
music, like you used to--
KUNAL GANJAWALA: No, no.
My father plays the
harmonica, so that
was the only musical influence.
And he would play that whenever
we were traveling on a holiday.
And he would play old
Indian songs, film songs.
But that was it.
And we were avid listeners.
So radio was a very
big medium and very big
influence, because we
didn't have internet radio,
or there was no stuff like that.
There was no internet.
So yeah, no, as such, musical
influence from the family,
besides my father
playing the harmonica.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
That's great, sir.
So how did you get your
first break in Bollywood?
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
I'd like to thank--
there was a very
senior musician,
a female singer called
Poornima, who we all know.
She was a child prodigy.
She sang with Kishore
Kumar, Rafi Sad, Mukeshji,
as a kid for-- Shankar
Jaikishanji, for RD Burman,
for SD Burman.
So she picked me up
from a college festival
in '92, around the time-- and
that shift from me not wanting
to do music and wanting to
take it up professionally
came around '92, '93.
So she picked me up,
and she introduced me
to Ranjit Barot, who's a very
senior musician in the country.
And Ranjit is a very, very
senior musician, singer,
songwriter, producer, drummer.
And Ranjit influenced me a lot.
My career took off after
he endorsed me in Bombay.
And so Ranjit is one
of the finest drummers
that India has produced.
And he has been drumming
for John McLaughlin
for the last six or seven years,
so he's part of John's band.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
So recently, you have shifted
more into music composition,
if that's correct.
So can you tell us more
about your recent projects
you're working on?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Yeah.
I'm getting ready with
all the ammunition,
because the whole model of
singers, composers, and lyric
writers, these were very
designated departments
in India from the time
film started in the '50s.
So you had the
great Madan Mohanji,
SD Burman, Shankar Jaikishan.
You had [INAUDIBLE],
you had [INAUDIBLE].
These were the great poets,
like you had [INAUDIBLE],
and then you had [INAUDIBLE].
So these with three
very important parts
of a song, the process.
Over the last decade, that has
changed, because what happens
is inevitably, a song
is known by the singer.
So you say, this is
a Kishore Kumar song.
This is a Rafi Sad song.
This is Lataji song.
And that's how it is.
There are very few who
realize that that's
a a great song by Rafi which was
composed by SD Burman, written
by [INAUDIBLE].
That's only music enthusiasts,
because you have to go beyond.
So that started kind of
affecting the composers,
modern composers.
They thought we were
taking away the shebang.
We were taking away all the
limelight off that song.
So what they
started doing, which
is what record labels in
the West started doing too,
which is taking away the--
[PHONE RINGING]
--which is taking away--
--which is taking
away-- no, that's fine.
Which is taking away the
power from an artist.
Oh, this artist is
becoming very big.
Let's clip their wings.
So this was part of that.
So the composers started saying
that, oh, this is my song.
That singer sung it, and he's
making millions out of it.
So the composers started
singing, which is fine.
But don't diss any
part of the food chain,
because we're not
doing this intently.
We're singers, so we sing.
Here's a great mandolin player.
He plays the mandolin.
This is a great piano player.
He plays the piano.
So we're just sticking
to what we're doing.
So the model changed.
So the singers was not
getting used as much
as they were 10 years ago,
because the composers started
singing, or the composers
started getting people they
know who they could control.
So it's a blessing, actually,
because every invention
comes out of necessity.
That made us-- being
kind of not as busy
as we used to be till five
years ago made us look within
and say, OK, so now I need to
write my songs and sing them,
because the guys who
are composing the songs
are singing them.
So that shift had to
happen from within.
And if we can interpret
composers' songs,
then we can write our
songs, too, we thought.
It can't happen every time.
A great composer can
be a great singer.
A great singer can be
a decent songwriter.
But we're trying.
So that's what we're trying.
And that independence
is fantastic,
because I did pray
to the god within.
When I was a new kid on the
block, 12, 13 years ago,
I said I don't want to depend
on anybody for my happiness.
So I'm glad that I have
my little home studio
and that I can write my
music and hit the road.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
That's great.
So are there any recent
projects that are coming along?
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
It's not that easy.
I may be a big name,
so to say, as a singer,
but I think I'm happy to do
independent music, which is not
connected to films, because
when you have to do films,
you have to be going back
and meeting the producers,
and that's not a
road I want to take,
because YouTube and independent
music is really big now.
I just want to keep writing
good music, by God's grace,
and want to collaborate
with great musicians who
have traveled on this trip and
do some music which kind of
makes me sleepless.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
So you have also
been really popular
in the Kannada film industry.
So are you focusing in that
space in in parallel, too?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: I've sung
about 250 songs in Kannada.
But what happens is the Kannada
industry feeds on the Bollywood
industry.
All the industries feed
on the Hindi industry.
So automatically, all
my contemporaries,
whether it's
[INAUDIBLE], whether it's
Shaan, whether it's KK, whether
it's Mohit, who came after us,
Mohit Chauhan, all of us-- the
quantity of work has gone down.
But we have enough
of a repertoire.
I've got about 1,200-plus songs,
including my Kannada songs
and Bengali songs and Punjabi
songs and Hindi songs.
So we have enough
for this lifetime
to pass by without
really knocking
on the doors of a
composer saying,
can you give me a
couple of more songs?
Let's party.
Let's hang out.
I can't hang out with people.
There's got to be
dignity in work.
And I'm old school.
I'm sorry, I don't like to--
I let my profession speak.
If I don't have the credentials
workwise, don't hire me.
But I can't suck up to you.
VIKAS MARWAHA: So did you learn
Kannada to sing Kannada songs?
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
I can understand
when people speak Kannada,
because every time I
write a Kannada song or a Tamil
song or a Telugu song-- yeah,
you heard Telugu, but I can't
sing Telugu, because this
is Telugu land, Silicon Valley.
So my brother-in-law,
my nephew, his father
is Karnataka, so my sister
is married into Karnataka.
But I can understand
conversational Kannada.
I can't speak it.
But I would write down--
I would break down
every line-- in
every language that I
sing in which I
don't understand,
I would write down what
the line means word by word
so that I could kind of
express what I'm singing.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
So I know you already
touched base on this,
but you've been in
Bollywood music industry
for more than a decade, and
you've seen a lot of changes.
What do you feel about the
current music being produced?
What are you hoping--
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Some of
the music that's coming out
is fabulous.
There's a singer
called Arijit Singh,
and I think he's phenomenal.
He's a great gift to the lineage
of all the great singers,
composers, that have happened.
And I'm very happy that someone
good is singing, because he
can sing in a lot of genres.
He's a very potent singer,
very competent singer.
He's got a great heart.
He's got a great vibe.
There's another singer
called Benny Dayal.
Benny is wonderful, too.
He sings the whole R&B thing.
That's his thing.
He sings R&B, essentially,
and he's wonderful.
So these two singers
really, really-- I
like listening to their music.
So there is a good crop and
some very nice songwriters.
There was a period till
about two years ago where
melody was-- there's
another singer,
a composer called
Jeet Ganguly, who's
writing some fabulous melody.
So melody is back.
And if you don't have melody,
you can keep making noise.
You can use all the gadgets,
possibly, that are available,
and all technology, but
if there's no melody,
there's nothing that can
hook you and hold you back.
So it's a great time in
the Hindi films, as well.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
As [INAUDIBLE] said, we
had Benny Dayal and Arijit
Singh for Talk at Google, too.
I hosted Benny Dayal,
so that's great
that you talked about them.
So finally, sir, you're
performing tonight
at ICC Milpitas for a very noble
cause you talked about earlier.
So what songs can the
audience expect from you
that will be joining you today?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: I have
about 45 chart-toppers,
so I can't do 45 chart-toppers
in 1 and 1/2 hours.
But I'll do an amalgamation
of-- I'll club as much as I can.
I'll do [INAUDIBLE], and
I'll do "Bheegey Hont."
I'll do at least 20 of
my chart-toppers, some
of them half, some of them
full, some of them as a medley.
And hope you guys are
happy and satisfied.
If you're not, I'll send
you my manager's number
and we'll come back.
But I'm honored to be sharing
the stage with Mandolin U.
Rajeshji and
[? Harmit. ?] I think
I'm very lucky to be on
the same stage as them,
because I really,
honestly feel they
bring so much more to my music.
And it's a pleasure.
It's been a couple of years
since we've known each other,
and it's fabulous.
I look forward to
today, because what
I'm going to do today, before
I bring in the Bollywood set,
I haven't done-- I haven't done.
So we look forward to those
butterflies in my tummy.
VIKAS MARWAHA: This is great.
I also look forward to
your concert tonight.
And now I'd like to open
the questions to Googlers
that we have here, if
they have any questions.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: No Googlese.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for coming here, sir.
In the recent, let's
say, five or seven years
there's been a big
trend in Bollywood music
to use synthesizers and so on.
Every time you see or
you listen to a song
where they've used either
an orchestra or at least
real, acoustic
instruments, it just
sounds completely different.
Why is this trend changing?
Why aren't we still
doing pure music
like we did in the old days?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: We've always
looked towards the West.
We've always looked at the
music that's happening in the US
and in Europe and UK.
So the trends are
changing there,
and our pop music has
a style quotient, also.
We've always looked at
the West, unfortunately.
And that has caused--
because there's
a lot of noise
happening even here.
You have great artists who
are not cutting records,
and you have a lot of
production, so to say,
produced, like you said-- just
lots of gear, but no melody.
There's lots of stuff
you hear-- and I
don't mean to diss
any of the music,
but you go back just 25
years or even 15 years
and you still had melody.
So we're like that.
We always look and say,
ah, that's happening.
We have great artists
like-- singers like Beyonce.
She's a fabulous singer, but
her producers are not even
writing stuff for her, which
she wrote in her first two
albums, Destiny's Child.
There were melodies.
Even something that
she wrote seven,
eight years ago,
still had melody.
But that's all changing.
And I think we as
consumers are to be blamed.
So if more responsible
people like you
start asking this question, stop
downloading music, paid music,
I think they'll
get their answers
and they'll start moving
and making a shift.
So we need to not
consume crap musically.
AUDIENCE: So as
someone who's creating
stuff that people
are paying for,
do you see a market for
pure or really [INAUDIBLE]?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Absolutely.
See, India, even our pop music
two, three years ago was noisy.
There was a shift, three
or four years of confusion,
whether we should have it
more electronic or what.
And suddenly, Jeet Ganguly
and Armaan Malik came in,
and they've brought melody.
So it's bound to happen.
And also, unfortunately,
record labels
control the artists too
much, and the songwriters.
They think they know what
sells, because they just
want to see the jacket.
They just want to see money.
And that's not going to change,
because every artist that
starts rebelling
gets thrown away
in the darkness,
like the greatest,
like Michael Jackson or
George Michael, from modern,
from current times.
And that's why Stevie's
not writing albums
after having written so many.
He wrote his last album
about 10 years ago.
So if you try to
fight the system,
the system just throws you--
chews you and throws you.
So it's upon consumption.
So if there is no demand,
there will be no supply.
So we have to
control the demand.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Hello, sir.
I'm [INAUDIBLE]
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm a big fan of yours.
What industry you like--
Kollywood, Bollywood,
or Dollywood, which
language, and which language
you want to sing?
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Actually,
I just love doing music,
so language is something--
and we are lucky that India
as a country, as small as
it is if you compare it
to the continents
and the landmass,
we have so many languages.
So I'm just lucky that I was
born in a country with so much
diversity and so much culture.
And for me, one of my
aunts-- one of my uncles
is married into [INAUDIBLE].
A sister is married
into Karnataka.
My wife is from Tamil Nadu.
The other sister is
married into Sindh.
So our home has been like--
my mother is from Maharashtra.
My granny was from Maharashtra.
And we are Gujaratis.
So we were already having
six or seven languages
within the family,
so it was fantastic.
It was like learning at home.
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] So it
was a natural inclination.
So I love singing--
singing, per se.
I love music.
So language is not a problem.
AUDIENCE: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
KUNAL GANJAWALA:
[NON ENGLISH SPEECH],
thank you, yes.
AUDIENCE: Talking to you.
Thank you.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Thank you.
I'd leave the
microphone now to you
to speak to the other artists.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
Thank you, Kunalji.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: I'm
horribly jet-lagged.
VIKAS MARWAHA: It was a
pleasure hosting you today.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Thank you, sir.
It was a pleasure being here.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Thank you.
Thank you once again.
KUNAL GANJAWALA: Thank you.
Thank you.
VIKAS MARWAHA: I'd
like you guys to have.
[APPLAUSE]
Well, so it's a
pleasure today that we
have two notable artists today
on the same day at Google.
Today we first had
Kunalji, who you all heard,
and now we have a very
famous mandolin player
of India, Mandolin U. Rajesh.
He is an exponent in
his craft and a leader
in pioneering world music.
He's composed several superhit
ensemble albums, including
"Following my
Heart," and performed
on John McLaughlin's
Grammy-nominated album
Floating Point.
A big round of applause in
welcoming him to Google today.
[APPLAUSE]
So Rajeshji, welcome to Google.
It's a pleasure that
you're here today among us.
Is this your first
time in Bay Area?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
No, I've been
coming for 15 years, at
least, to the Bay Area.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
That's great, sir.
And this is the first
time you're probably
performing with Kunalji, right?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: It's
a first-time combination.
I'm really looking
forward to that.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
That's great.
He really looked excited
working with you.
Will be great.
So, sir, as you know, Google
is a technology company.
And I would like to know,
since technology is playing
an increasing role
in everyone's life,
how do you see technology
impacting the reach
and impact on the mandolin?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: Of
course, my instrument
is completely dependent on
technology, electric mandolin.
But technology is like
a pickle in the food.
It's not mainstream.
It gives added value.
But you should not
completely depend on it.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's true.
So there have been-- so are
you using YouTube as a medium
to promote your music,
like a lot of artists,
independent artists these days?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: YouTube
is an amazing thing,
which it's like a blessing,
because those days, you want
to listen to different
kind of music,
you have to go
personally buy, search.
Now you just keyword
and you can see.
That's a blessing.
VIKAS MARWAHA: I mean, do you
have your own YouTube channel?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
Yeah, of course.
We do have YouTube channels,
and it's a great way to--
VIKAS MARWAHA: It's a great way
to connect with the audience.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
Yeah, that's right.
And so you have played
with a number of bands,
with international musicians,
including Pete Lockett, Bickram
Ghosh, and Stephen Devassy.
In this way you have
been a pioneering wave
of fusion music.
That's great.
I would love to know, how
do you define fusion music,
and what are your thoughts
in its growth in popularity
over the past several decades?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
Well, life changes.
Change is permanent.
Fusion in music is-- there's
nothing called fusion music.
It's just trying to--
it's like food, you know?
You have cuisines,
multi cuisines.
Now we have every cuisine
in our house cooking.
We just have some fried rice.
Likewise in music.
It's nice to collaborate,
and it's basically conversing
in a different language.
Fusion is nothing but two
languages trying to talk,
and we come to a point where we
get understanding the language.
That's fusion music.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's true.
So we all know your late
brother, U Srinivas,
who was an undisputed
wizard on the mandolin.
Can you share with us more about
his influence on your music?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
Of course, he
is the person who
brought this instrument
to the Indian classical music.
He was the first person,
and he is everything
for me-- inspiration.
He is my guru.
He's brother.
He is my guiding
light, everything.
And without him, I would have
not been a musician at all.
I just wanted to become
a pilot, actually.
So it's karma or accident
that incident just happened.
And he's just a great blessing
to our Indian classical music,
because what he did is--
Indian music has been there
for thousands of years, but
he brought a new instrument,
and then brought the old format
of music to the world again.
And he made Western
people go, wow,
because mandolin is more
a romantic instrument,
plays more of harmony.
And he adapted it
and modified it
to play the mainstream
Indian classical music, which
is very difficult. There's a
lot of long notes, long slide
notes, [INAUDIBLE].
He's the person who
made the difference
to Indian classical music.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Did he used to
play mostly electric mandolin?
Is that right?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: He
started with an acoustic,
then he realized that
Indian classical music needs
more sustained notes, so he
added the element of pickup
and made it more electric.
VIKAS MARWAHA: I've been
following recently [INAUDIBLE].
He plays electric
version of a sitar,
so this is amazing, how you guys
are bringing the Indian music
through instruments like these
with beautiful harmonies.
So sir, how did your
training happen?
Tell us more about how many
hours you put into training,
and how did you used to train?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
Let me be very honest.
I was not-- wanted
to be a musician.
I wanted to become a pilot.
And when I was six I
started learning it
because my dad is a strict
dad and I have to learn it.
If not, I'll get nicely whacked.
But when I was 10
or 11 years old,
I met this great saint Indian.
He lived for 100
years, [INAUDIBLE].
And he said no
piloting, only music.
Because they don't talk
much, very few words.
And that was the day I performed
first, like my brother.
And my life's
changed from there.
It all started like that.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's so great.
So you're involved with efforts
to groom the next generation
of classical
musicians, including
at the Srinivas Institute of--
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: [INAUDIBLE]
Institute of World Music,
and we teach music for free.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
That's great, sir.
And how many
students do you have?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
We have students
all over the world--
probably 150, 200 students.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
Do you guys have any plans
of opening the institute here
[INAUDIBLE]?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: Yeah.
We're planning to open
it in East Coast first,
and then Bay Area later.
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
Looking forward to it.
So what has been your experience
imparting the learnings
to the next
generation, and can you
tell us about the next
generation of mandolin
minstrels that are coming out?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
Speaking about generations,
I'm still young.
VIKAS MARWAHA:
Oh, yeah, I agree.
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
I've been talking
about the next generation.
We don't need to be worried
about the generations,
because as long as your music is
pure and perfect and very good,
it just keeps going on.
That's what my brother believed
in, and it's still going on.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Sir, I
know you have brought
your mandolin here,
and everyone here
would love to hear you play.
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: I will
just play a little bit
and just show you the
changes which my brother did.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
--sounds, and what
is the changes.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[INAUDIBLE]
[APPLAUSE]
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's amazing
how you stayed on that note,
like the latter you played.
That was mind blowing.
Great.
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: [INAUDIBLE]
VIKAS MARWAHA: I'll open
up to audience questions
for Rajeshji.
People are mind blown, man.
They're really looking forward
to seeing your performance
tonight.
That's great.
Thank you, Rajeshji,
so much for coming.
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH: It's my
pleasure to be here to Google,
and thank you for inviting.
And we are very
honored and blessed
to be here for that
SAI global organization
for doing this wonderful
fundraiser for Swami's
hospital.
Thank you all and, hope
to see you all there.
[INAUDIBLE]
VIKAS MARWAHA: That's great.
I guess we got a question now.
AUDIENCE: This is a little
bit of an oddball question,
and hopefully you
have an opinion.
But ever since I've been
watching music, and especially
musicians in India, I rarely
see women come forward.
There are a few, but there's
certainly a lot more men
that are famous in this field.
Why is that?
MANDOLIN U. RAJESH:
That's a tricky question.
You should ask women,
not me, because-- there
are a lot of women
learning the instrument.
Probably women are
created by God,
because there's beauty, this
so much, you forget everything
when you see the beauty.
And men trying hard to be
listened and take the place.
It's just a tricky question.
I don't see that women are less.
Everywhere, if you see in
rock, pop, [INAUDIBLE],
there are a lot of women
singing and playing instruments.
I don't see less women in
here in this profession.
I mean, that's my opinion.
I may be wrong.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
VIKAS MARWAHA: Well, thank
you, Rajeshji, again.
It was a pleasure.
And thank you all for
coming for today's event.